what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday the 1st of december
the joint is brought to you by my
[__] savages draftkings listen
football season's in full effect mba is
in full effect college football is in
full effect ufc this weekend's in full
effect the nhl is in full effect and
draftkings is here to make sure you earn
some extra cash before the [__]
holidays new customers who bet just one
dollar on any team to score can win a
hundred dollars in free bets it's that
simple you'll be a winner when one point
is scored listen i love draftkings they
have a stat hub they have a social
network you know what sometimes i'm
confused on a pick i go to the stat hubs
and they give me a [__] winner i talk
to other players there's even a guy on
patreon on there talking with me if
sportsbook isn't available in your state
either draftkings won't let you down
they have a tremendous draftkings daily
fantasy
sports contest
draftkings is giving all new customers a
free shot at millions of [__]
dollars in total prizes with their first
deposit and you're sitting there like a
[__] mukyok waiting what the [__] are
you waiting for it's fast it's secure
it's fun and [__] reliable you bet
twenty dollars on a [__] game and you
get some enjoyment last night i bet what
the [__] did i bet monday night i bet
the first team to score and the under on
the [__] washington game it was
[__] tremendous
so give it a shot columbus did you're
sitting there like a [__] mook bored
to death this is a way you can make some
money
little money and have [__] fun
watching sports nobody knows nothing
draftkings is safe secure and reliable
and best of all you can withdraw your
cash whatever the [__] you want download
the draftking sportsbook app today we
got ufc this weekend we got [__] jose
aldo we got mickey gall we got [__] i
mean that's a [__] great card so
whether you're a ufc type of guy a
boxing type of guy a soccer type of guy
draftkings has it all and don't make me
talk to you about the [__] casino
they got a [__] blackjack they got
live dealers for blackjack they got a
[__] gambling room that's live that
will blow you the [__] away they run
happy hours at night when you're sitting
there bored to death so do me a favor
like i'm saying download the draftking
sportsbook app today use promo code joey
grow down a dollar on any team to score
and win 100 in free bets and you're
always with the [__] champions
draftkings they're the official betting
partner of the nfl the nba and the major
league football and the ufc and the
[__] nhl what does that tell you all
right you got to be 21 older new jersey
indiana pennsylvania west virginia
colorado
you're invited new customers only
minimum five dollar deposit and a dollar
wager required i know you got a [__]
dollar cop something and i know you got
five hours to open the account one per
customer don't be [__] greedy
restrictions apply see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details now if you got a
gaming problem i don't want to [__]
uh you know get you all rambled up you
can't get in trouble with draftkings
because you only deposit from a card or
your paypal it's like you could bet over
your head but if you have a problem call
1-800 gambler if you don't
get your [__] together download the
draftking sportsbook app and let's make
some [__] kids this week again
you want to start out 2022 in the best
[__] mind space in the best shape of
your life to get healed start with cbd
lion listen i owe a lot to cbd lion
those [__] creams
that thousand milligram cream i had a
[__] i was walking with a limp for
three days because i bought adidas with
a [__]
the thing came in him and my foot it
crushed my [__] arch let me tell you
something i put that cbd cream on my
foot and i put a little ice on there tip
top magoo three days i put a little bit
of the cbd tape around the [__] thing
in my ankle
when i went to walk around with my
adidas on and it feels great the cbd
[__] lion gummies are tremendous they
got melatonin and they'll help you go to
sleep they got a tremendous ice they got
a tincture they got the [__] reefer
that gets you not high but they'll put c
listen no matter how you want to put cbd
into your system cbd lion has the answer
and it's the best cbd in the market how
do i know because they put me through a
[__] surgery so do me a favor go to
cbdline.com right now
read the third party lab results and
just read learn about cbd
they'll let you know what you need their
creams are cruelty free
free gluten-free vegan organic
third-party lab tested non-gmo thc free
iso 7 certified and manufactured in the
u.s of a do me a favor
when you order something press in joey
i'll get you 20 off delivered right to
your [__] house you don't have
to go to a gas station or talk to a guy
behind a liquor store [__]
bulletproof window cbd line is right
here for you go to cbdlion.com
press enjoy joint and get 20 off
delivered to your house now without
further ado
let's get this [__] party started i
gotta get a new candle back here i
almost just lit my hand on fire
welcome to uncle joy's joy
[Music]
so
what's happening you beautiful
[__] welcome to another episode
of the [__] uncle joey's joint it's
wednesday december [__] first the
holiday
season is in full [__] effect
[__]
you better start [__] getting your
gifts now you got what 24 shoplifting
days left to make it [__] work for
your [__] i don't know how that
will work for you but
i'm good
been a great [__] week so far uh
i'm happy a lot of you guys are watching
true story
a lot of you guys get hit me back and
said you enjoyed it they never saw kevin
our heart act that way and stuff i
i watched all seven episodes i thought
it was [__] great
he inspired me man he really did i got
inspired twice this week i watched 60
minutes and i watched rita moreno
[__] 90 years old still acting and
here i'm 58 i think i'm dead
i'm brand [__] new now after i saw
her at 90 moving around and doing a
thing
and i tell you what kevin hart kevin
hart's an inspirational [__] guy i
just read an interview with him
yesterday
that he's gonna work until he becomes a
[__] billionaire
and it's not about the money for him
it's just to prove a [__] point you
know
and he's just uh he's a good comic to
[__] watch like i've always been a
fan of his from afar
i've always liked how he handled his
business but
this tv show what he said on the show he
said a couple things on there that
really rang
[__] big with me so if you get a
chance
watch true story you'll [__] like it
uh what else is
yeah no even jimmy's watching it with
his kid i mean everybody was like joey
thank you for the recommendation again i
don't think the [__] series is an
academy award-winning series but it's
great to watch wesley snipes you know
it's so weird how
you only get better at something the
more you stick with it
you really do and then it switches in
your mind
like
i always wanted to act and now more than
ever like after seeing rita moreno
do that thing about [__] she's 90 and
she was she dated [__] marlon brando
for eight years it hit me so much i had
to watch apocalypse now last night you
know what i'm saying like i didn't watch
the whole thing because three [__]
hours and it's the redux it's on netflix
and i hate that [__] when the french
have you seen that when they go visit
the french it's just too long i like the
old movie you know
but [__] uh tonight i'll get to watch
marlon brando cause i only watched one
hour last night i watched martin sheen
with the acid trip in the beginning
oh
hey close the door
[__] way way way way raised and he
and he lays back down they tell him his
mission and he lays back down martin
sheen
and they're like come on help me up here
we got a live one they throw him in the
[__] shower i mean he's so [__] up
he didn't hit an acid for that [__]
scene he tripped on yeah in real life he
was on acid in that scene [__]
tremendous i mean i love all that [__]
when he goes to the house to meet with
the [__] congressman and [__] that's
uh who's the who's the actor that keeps
crashing his plane
he's old harrison ford
harrison ford is in that movie young
young [__] young that other guy uh
the black dude that was in the matrix
um
yeah yeah the best actor of [__] all
time he's from lawrence fishburne
lawrence fishburne is 16 years old i
don't know if you guys remember that one
day me and ralphie were standing by the
formosa cafe waiting to get that weed
store you had to wait online outside and
it was just me and ralphie get into a
conversation outside we weren't even
waiting online no more there was nobody
else out there it was just me and him
the people kept saying come in come in
but we're like we're just out here
talking we're going to hit the chinese
formosa and all of a sudden
we look up in a car parks
and we didn't you know cars park all the
time you know
me and ralph be like you know sitting
there talking [__] and all of a sudden
lawrence fishburne gets out of the
[__] car he's coming to the weed
store
and he walks up to us and i had piazzo
comedy slam was on show time and he
looked at me goes man were you on show
time last night oh yeah it goes bro i
really enjoyed it and all of a sudden me
ralphie and lawrence fishburne are
having a [__] conversation on formosa
for 20 minutes the people inside the
wheat store banging in the glass like
come in we're about to close and we're
like wait up hold on because ralphie
would go in there to spend two thousand
dollars i had no money i was riding on
ralphie ralphie goes in there we all go
in and now we're in the weed store with
lawrence [__] fishburn and the guy
says are you with him and lawrence goes
yeah and my dick got really hot i'm like
oh [__] lawrence [__] digs us so
[__] we started talking we went
outside
and we started bullshitting more and
that's when he went into the whole
apocalypse now story how he was 16. his
family had to go down there with him
they shot in the philippines me and
ralphie were like holy [__] we're over
here hanging out with lawrence fishburn
if he whips out a joint and sparks it
we're gonna die we smoke with lauren's
[__] fish burn i can tell people to
suck my dick and we hung out with
lawrence fishman i remember that night
he's uh you act i go yeah and uh he goes
uh
i'm gonna hook you up with an acting
class
and i was like [__] lawrence
fishburne's gonna hook me up with an
acting class so he hooked me and this
kid rick ramos up and we went to that
acting teacher for like 90 days he was
expensive as [__] and i booked a couple
jobs and the schedules were [__]
weird the guy was real eccentric and
[__] but that's my lawrence fishburne
story i never got to work with him but i
[__] got to
talk to him and [__] with him and
that was listen man that
to me
he was so cool and he just told us
little details
about the movie you know how he had to
sleep outside the tent the mosquitoes
they had to keep taking shots because
the mosquitoes like uh what do you call
it like vaccinations and [__]
it was just [__] tremendous man those
kind of he's a true [__] star that
guy you know it's and the other [__]
guy from the matrix that we'd see every
morning for breakfast
was keanu reeves for a while i would go
to duke's restaurant me ralphie mike
faberman josh wolfe we were going there
10 deep to dukes they used to give me a
cheese omelet
with [__] house
the steak fries [__] tremendous i was
up to like 400 pounds every time i ate
there but every time we walked out
keanu reeves is there
sitting just eating reading the l.a
times by himself people would say hello
he'd say hello because he was there
every morning so you just got used to
him every morning what's happening
yeah
after the matrix he was there i remember
after i met him like he was so cool that
actually went to see one of his movies
where he plays like a [__] felon
that's he has to uh do a uh be a coach
to a a kid's baseball team for them to
[__] for him to do is
yeah yeah yeah we went to see that movie
[__] i love all that [__] i love
movies i [__] love movies you know i
just got to get myself a little stronger
agent in new york the guy i got now is
great but he books theaters he doesn't
really book theatrical so it's hard for
him to book me but i think i'm going to
call big [__] i'm going to call vincent
and see if he can hook me up with one of
his agents so he knows any agents that
would take me i don't even know what my
[__] reel is
like i haven't added anything to my
reels since 2010. you're supposed to add
everything you do if you look at my reel
it's got like [__] boilermaker and
[__] like that i don't even think i put
boilermaker on there i was really into
that like every time i i couldn't wait
to shoot some
to put it on my reel but every time you
put something on your reel it's a deuce
and then you have to duplicate tapes
with that new reel so whatever reels you
have that are old they go guts you you
send them out that world is done now now
are we there's no people don't even send
[__] i think i i do have
there's a thing called actors access
that has all your information it tells
you everything from your you know what
parts are out let me tell you some
actors access is like
12 bucks a month and i can i could give
you five jobs i booked off there were
sag union jobs i booked coke case from
actors access because when the show
wasn't popping i did the first season so
they put it out on regular things
actress access is a great [__] actors
uh if you're booking yourself like these
people i can't find an agent it's a
catch-22
so what you have to do is go on actors
access book a little bit
get those [__] uh put those on your
resume and then you go to an agent and
they're like how did you book cocaine's
act as access [__] i don't need you
that much either so you let them know
that you have actors access i look at it
now from time to time it's all non-union
stuff and
you know the last thing i submitted
meant for was the fat man show about a
year ago on that i resigned up when i
moved here i never got a call back but
they're all great resources to have
if you're thinking about acting and now
after i saw that rita moreno thing
i want to act i want to really get back
into it and uh i'm not listening if you
think i'm going to go to an acting class
and try to be like accents and [__] now
that's my problem i got no range as an
actor i'm only one thing i'm only three
things a cop
a mobster a [__] garbage man
a burglar i always play burglars i love
those roles something in jail you know
something that's in a prison those are
my characters and i accept it for what
it is i'm not gonna go in there and try
to play an english guy and try to be
chip chip charlie ho it's not gonna
[__] work guys i am not the guy from
[__] the fighter you know that guy's
the best actor he's the best white
[__] actor the guy from the fighter
but uh yeah that that's it and that's
that man we have a great week going guys
i'm feeling a lot better you know how i
know because i motherfucked three people
yesterday that's how i know i'm feeling
better when i feel people taking me for
granted
that's when i [__] go off but you
know what i was a little upset yesterday
i smoked a little laughing gas
and we're back i'm still just smoking
one joint at night my [__] i was
thinking of pissing a bottle just to see
where my weed level is at
just to see because i remember what the
cc's were when i was like emboldering
[__] i like to see how much tac i have
in my system now but i gotta tell you
something guys i haven't eaten an edible
in a while
because i ran out of them i'm not gonna
lie to you it's not like i quit i ran
out of them when you run out of them you
got no options this is jersey but i'm
thinking of making like tonight i was
thinking of making a [__] nice uh
ten of brownies i make some great
[__] brownies get some walnuts and
[__] put an eighth of that [__]
laughing gas and cook it nice with some
nice butter
ooh
uncle joey's brownies will [__] kill
you
if you think the [__] stars are that
they'll kill you because as i'm making
the brownies every time i put that thc
butter into that brownie mix and stir it
up i lick that spoon by the time the
brownies come out of the oven you're
like [__]
you're all [__] up
but uh i'm going to an n a meeting
tomorrow just to check it listen guys
i gotta give a little something back you
know uh i went through a hard time this
year and
what i found when you have a hard time
that gets you through it again i'm i'm
boring as [__] but i believe in the
journal i did a lot of journaling
during this and i went to therapy during
this time which i've never been to
before in my life it's been [__]
great
i go on better help every monday and i
talk to dana for 20-25 minutes
and it gives me a little [__] peace
of mind you know i was one of those guys
that never believed in therapy
and now like i like even in the [__]
uh
true story
his manager
has a therapist and i guess the
therapist get but when
his concerns were
kevin like in the in this show that i'm
watching true story i finished it last
night or two nights ago but
uh
what the [__] we talking about
the manager had a therapist and it was
funny when the therapist called him back
the guy had a therapist to deal with
kevin you know
he really did
because it's so overwhelming when you're
a manager and the same happens on the
other end
when you're a comic you deal with so
many people you know your agency has
three people calling you all the time
your agent his assistant and the
receptionist
and you deal with those three [__]
people and
then you deal with your manager and his
assistant and everybody else that
[__] calls you you know and you
when you're a comic you just get you
talk to these people all [__] day by
the time you get on stage you don't even
know what side is right you don't know
whether you're coming or you're going
and i think after a while it drives you
[__] crazy you know you have to keep
it's like tom fired his manager over the
pandemic a lot of people made booze over
pandemic because they realized they
didn't need these people no more these
people were just getting in their way
you know
and uh like for me i'm hollywood free
right now i talk to i have a podcast
agent she helps me out with everything i
i throw all the jobs now that my agent
used to get my agent don't return my
calls he don't want to know what the
[__] i'm doing so
i'm doing it all on my own that's why i
went back to actors access to like you
know like you gotta find i got matt
fultron coming on today and we talked
about on the podcast today that
you don't need those [__] pukes
anymore you don't even need to be around
them i don't want their [__] words
going into my brains and [__] nothing
i don't want to talk to those people
anymore at all i'm switching to a new
york agency and i'm gonna [__] go for
it whether i do stand up next year or
tomorrow who the [__] knows i'm not
gonna stress it no more when i feel it
it's in my nutsack i'll be ready to
[__] go
you know right now i'm just happy to be
90 back
90 back i'm getting hard-ons
everything's [__] beautiful
i always get hard-ons i'm lying to you i
get mysterious hard-ons i get hard-ons
when i'm driving you never get a hard-on
when you get it when you're after 50.
they always pop up it's like when you're
eight years old
yeah when you're eight your dick pops up
out of nowhere my friend was telling me
her son came up the other day with a
hard dick and said mommy what's wrong
with it it's gonna break and she goes
don't touch it it's gonna it might break
or something you know yeah he showed up
with a hard you ever show your mom your
dick i remember how to show my mom my
dick one time
i was like 14. i was really ashamed so i
woke her up in the middle of night and
showed it to her she's like what oh yeah
you might have to go see a doctor
in that way
but i my mom fell asleep watching tv and
i remember i went up on her with my dick
and she's like what the [__] is wrong
with you she was like what the [__] is
wrong with she can't show me i had to
dub my dick like right here because it
was dark in the room and they just like
put the light on let me see i'm hungover
and that was the end of that
but i showed my mom my dick on something
my boy you know you bang one out and you
have to stop and mid bang out the
[__] sperm goes backwards and it
clogs your [__] vein or something
like that you get like a spoiling the
next day that's what happens when you're
a kid i don't know when you're [__]
50. anyway without further ado my
brother mr matt [__] fultron the full
charge [__] i'll check with you
welcome to afterwards joey's joy
[Music]
yo
what's up my brother from a different
mother
good to see you
the movie star what's up my man welcome
to the [__] joint finally it's great
to be here so close yet so far away now
where are you you're in the city i'm in
brooklyn yeah okay how's it going out
there it's going just fine you know we
got any garbage on your street
what's that you got any garbage on your
street oh plenty of garbage half of it's
mine you know last time i went to the
city i saw a lot of [__] garbage
brother
oh yeah what was that
that was moving uh that night the 22nd
when i saw you at the beacon
yeah we stopped at a pizza parlor and i
was eating the pizza outside because
they just started the
you know the covert thing yeah and i
went outside to eat the pizza and all of
a sudden i saw a rat
the size of my [__] foot his tail was
bigger than a [__] black dude's dick
that's been in jail for 20 years that
tail was [__] long and thick yeah god
damn these rats never [__] slowed
down
no they're getting citizenship these
days man it's ridiculous you have to
they fight you see the videos in new
york are the rats running with pizzas
and
yeah i saw one about a year ago with a
chicken wing you know it's [__]
i mean when i was a kid there were rats
at my godmother's house and she told me
that
the rat attacked the kid upstairs and
they breathe on you while they bite you
or some [__] like that's why you
couldn't go to bed with sticky fingers
yeah you wash your hands and [__] i
would keep the staying at my godmothers
to a minimum i would put little mouse
traps around my little [__] bed in
the back i hated it i [__] hate those
things dude we were walking down the
street in the summertime one time my
fiance had sandals on and this rat just
ran straight out of one trash can and
and just walked ran right over her foot
them little fingers just grabbed onto
her feet and pushed off
she jumped a mile high man i bet she did
and you would have seen my chubby ass i
would have been like nasa i would have
been [__] up there in the air and i
would have landed and chased that
[__] rat bastard i'm not scared of
them i just don't like them close to me
like if they get close to me i'll hit
them with a stick i used to kill rats in
new york as a kid i bet me and my little
buddies on 88th street would chase them
we would see them in the daylight chase
them and those kids were brutal they
would beat them with sticks
then [__] hit them with rocks then
they'd get their father to run over him
and then we would light the [__]
on fire when he was a pancake and [__]
we were ruthless on 88th street dude
serial killer training ground
[__] hate those [__] what's
going on with you my man nothing dude
i'm just uh resurrecting the career
getting back to work
i do spots at gotham and uh old man
hustle and all the indie shows i can
muster around
the
east side comedy club
east eastville or east side east side i
think they have one on fifth street and
one uptown
never done east side i've done eastville
which is now in
brooklyn like close to downtown
uh i've done that place but east side i
don't know there's a lot of clubs here
some of them aren't even that popular
and you don't even really know about
them and then you're walking down the
street and you're like there's a [__]
comedy club it's a comedy club i mean
who goes to like stand up new york
anymore i don't hear nobody say to me i
do such a stand of new york nobody goes
to the commerce strip
i don't know if that's open i hear
nobody
yeah that's weird it goes uptown those
uptown clubs nobody goes to so much nope
we were right around the corner
when we were at the beacon theater we
were like two blocks away from i know
the uptown whatever that is up there on
77th street or something like yeah i
don't know
i played the beacon theater before
opening
yeah did you really [__] awesome we
did two shows i was hungover from my
borgata show in atlantic city it was one
of the few nights we stayed the night
you know usually we got it on the tour
bus and we left but i stayed the night
and drank way too much whiskey and i was
out of practice and i got hungover and i
puked for the first time in
years and then rode into uh
to new york on the bus just feeling like
[__]
and then like you know
reluctantly went on stage and just
started killing and just loving it and
to show that just like completely gave
the life back to me man that place is
amazing i love this is amazing it is
[__] amazing i was a [__] here from
doing it
yeah oh before the panda because i did
the next obvious choice was the beacon i
had done town hall so i was going to go
i'm going to go up to the upper west
side with the pips up there
but i think it seats like 2 000. it's
awesome it's [__] awesome it's
perfect
and who was there when we were there
last [__] dinero robert de niro
[__] boys walked out on stage that
was so great that was crazy when he
walked out with his little suit with
jane and [__] i loved him
i loved them people yeah
he [__] up everything that guy he
[__] up he hates all that stuff the
last premiere i went with that
[__] he fell asleep
he was in front of me sleeping with a
little italian hat on
when i woke up
i go mr d wake up
i just had to close my eyes for a second
me and my buddy still where i went to
thanksgiving he went with me to that for
me and he we were still laughing about
it that day he's old man i couldn't
imagine having to go to [__] three
movies a week come on make them believe
you're into it and they're shitty movies
i can see it like they're old movies and
you know the premiere you got to go and
tell the people he did a great job oh my
god the movie was horrible you know
right sort of like my movie [__] i
i don't know what the [__] happened with
it but listen for me
when i was shooting it i said listen i
don't give a [__] if this movie bombs
i'm doing it for me yeah i can ever do
something for you
absolutely man i love i love the movie
i'm a big sopranos fan so i got all the
jokes and everything and i [__] love
seeing you up there and you got to see
yourself get your face shot off with how
many people get to see that in their
life
and let me tell you something at first i
was like
i don't know if i'm gonna like this like
people thought i had something to do
with it
like i have friends and people on
patreon they're like dawg you shouldn't
have gotten shot
i have three or four people
bob lalings the guy i visited on
thursday
a couple people on patreon a couple
people on twitter wrote me messenger
like hey man we turned it off as soon as
you got shot like that right you can't
do that to us
we don't want to see that we don't
people were crying we don't need that
[__] they said that when they saw my
picture in the city like at the wake
they were like we didn't need to see
that yeah
don't listen to us it's the sopranos
dude somebody's going to get shots
that's how it is and i always had listen
when i saw joe pesci get shot in good
fellas yeah that's the coolest thing in
the world
right shot in the mob movie like you're
gonna they're gonna remember you
you're gonna go up to them and say how's
joe diaz he got shot
yeah that's it they always remember you
for getting [__] shot and i don't
give a [__] for me it was
it was uh play time cops and rubs i
thought it was cool as [__] i thought it
was cool as [__] man i thought it was
cool as [__] too in my heart yeah yeah i
had a great time and all those guys i
was on the screen with we're all
dynamite young men i speak to all of
them
they check in with their uncle joey it
brings the tear to my eye but they're
just [__] people and great
hell [__] yeah some of the best actors
around john bernthal and the other guy
alessandro did a good job i i love mass
uh
gandalfini oh [__] it
he's getting a lot of love now man
yeah are they gonna do another are they
gonna do another movie because i would
love to see gandolfini keep going in
that character i would love to see again
finney
i'm not sure i'm not you know at least
someone
for me what do you want me to call the
people once a week what are we doing the
movie i can't
if they want to call me and include me
in their love i'm in but if not that's
fine too it would have to be a a prequel
to the prequel if you're going to be
here right yeah it would have to be a
prequel to the prequel to the prequel so
i but chase has done crazy things
absolutely okay
you know what chase does a lot
more than once is twins
he does twins like yeah we shot this guy
but his twin brothers right here yeah
yeah he's done that like three times i
think
yes he did it in the sopranos he did it
ray liotta yeah who else and somebody
else i think well there was there was
steve buscemi had twins neither of them
died but then you had uh philly's
brother got shot and he was a twin
uh so to me that's three that's like a
lot of twins
for one series you're a [__] genius
because i never even thought of that
twins you just [__] opened up a whole
thing to me listen
give it like i just saw something that
uh will farrell and his buddy got into a
fight
yeah yeah adam mckay yeah adam mckay
because he hired
what's his name first or something yeah
i've never i used to be like that when
people waste your time like people come
to the comedy store we're here to see
you for this movie and then they bust
your chop ten times and then at the end
you don't hear them anymore right and
you're like what happened also you see
the movie advertising like what happened
to my [__] role and they give it to
some other jamaican the movie bombs and
then yeah you're like [__] you
[__] parks at all you and all your
grandmothers
but
i used to have that little thing to me
now i just wish him luck if i audition
for a movie and i do a good job that's
all i could do yeah it's up to them
there's so many factors
think about it they've been wanting to
put you in the sopranos for years i was
just watching an episode the other day i
watch it all the time
and the fbi agent mentions joey coco
like you've been on their radar and it's
because of your auditions in the past
that you've been on their radar you
didn't get it at the time you got it
later yeah [__] cool and you had
something to do during the pandemic
right were you shooting during the
pandemic you must have been two days
okay remember last year we had to do
reshoots or attitudes we shot the uh the
confirmation scene
in brooklyn that was done in your
neighborhood right we all did that in
two days
right so it broke into two parts so
monday we did uh all this stuff in the
courtyard and then tuesday we did
my scene with ray liotta and you know
father [__] and all that the guy he's a
great guy the guy that played the priest
i had a blast at that [__] dude
that's what his name is in my phone mike
the priest
[Laughter]
i'm gonna give him a call today because
i he wants to take me to lunch up north
he's up uh like nayak so he's yeah just
come up to northbrook and we'll do some
[__] lunch
i got to bring you over my wife said to
me i said she goes who's on the podcast
tomorrow i go matt and she goes she's
coming over i'm going now he's in
brooklyn i thought you were in the city
i got a car i got a car so she told she
said tell that [__] to get in
the car and come down and see us we got
great food down here we got mikey down
here
we got blues i got booze down here i
don't [__] drink it i got heinekens
for you i got anything no alcohol for
you i'll bring my fiance down there yeah
you like chinese
i love chinese i absolutely love chinese
we got some good china here it's all
good good everything down here
i talked to this uh ufc fighter mickey
gall the other day
he's a great guy
yeah and he called me i called him to
wish him luck this week you know he's
fighting saturday in the ufc
and we were chit chatting and [__] he's
like how do you like it down there he
goes i got an aunt that lives down there
she used to go to new york all the time
for dinner she stopped about eight years
ago she says the food down there is
great it's great down here uh atlantic
city is great yeah red bank is great i
think mikey just went there red bank got
some good steakhouses and [__] got an
ant over there yeah yeah they got some
comedy theaters down there it's a nice
you know new brunswick got a nice
steakhouse
mm-hmm new jersey's [__] rocking you
know what i'm saying
it still stinks like dick when you're on
the turnpike dog i mean
the other day i was in the turnpike i'm
like if i could fart like this i would
[__] make a million dollars a year
like the fart on demand
that stink while you get to new york
right when you get to newark airport
like elizabeth from the south coming up
south yeah matt you got to smell that
it's true oh i do
and if you see a little puddle that's
been stagnant there for a while you can
see the cancer cells growing in it you
can see like it's got like a little
[__] uh little iv line for i mean
it's it's
you know yeah listen if you live in
jersey you're eventually gonna get
cancer there's something electrical
poles
uh you know something that'll [__] you
up yeah you know that used to be a joke
yeah like jersey was where they put all
the trash
it's the truth yeah staten island in
jersey you go to staten island it smells
like [__] i love staten island i tell
you i [__] love
i love the people from staten island
across the street it makes me [__]
spaghetti
once a week her husband's knocking on my
door hey my wife sent you this
yesterday she sent me pasta fazoo it's
spaghetti it's uh soup and beans and
[__] green stuff and
protein
dog that blew a [__] you got out of
the car you almost died
when i do come over my fiance is going
to make us meatballs we're going to
bring them she makes the best [__]
meatballs she's italian you'll [__]
love it done done now you spent that
whole pandemic in new orleans not the
whole pandemic i spent
from first of all i got a call from you
this is the first gig canceled you
called me up we were supposed to play
niacc
and i was like and you and you were like
we can't do it they're not you know it's
not happening and i remember thinking
man me and joey's gig is the only one
that get canceled
and then everybody's getting canceled
but uh
so i was in new orleans from march
until
september
and uh
it was it was a rough scene dude this is
a popular podcast i don't want to step
on any toes with my in-laws but you know
how it is i'm used to
being an independent guy i'm used to
being you're a comedian you get it like
you just go on your own schedule nobody
puts their two cents into your life
at all and there i was
with my future and mother-in-law
and dealing and my extended in-laws are
down there and it was just a whole
scenario everybody wanted to see each
other before the the vaccines came out
and everybody was just like it was just
like way more people in my business than
i was used to
and i eventually got an airbnb
down there and just kind of
got away from the family i was like this
is getting too crazy and i got away and
just lived in new orleans by myself
how was the pandemic down there
like when they shot all those bars down
and all that [__] how was the attitude
you just you know you got to know i
didn't get out of the house much so i
didn't see it but you got to know that's
what new orleans is all about
they uh
they their their whole thing like mardi
gras got canceled that was devastating
to everybody and it's a very social very
party town and it was just
gone but then there was some people who
you know like everywhere after a while
we're just like [__] it we're gonna see
each other we're gonna do the best we
can
without
getting too close to each other or blah
blah blah blah blah so i didn't really
leave the house till i got vaccinated uh
we we ended up back in new york from
september through january and that that
was like that sucked too
because me and my fiance were just
crammed into a two-bedroom apartment and
it felt like night of the living dead
just walking around
you know uh and it was cold to walk
around it was brutal man so then we went
back my fiancee's mom sold no she bought
a new house but kept the old one so i
went back in the beginning of 2021 and
that was a whole different thing we had
our own house we it looked like we were
crashing there like punk rockers because
it was a big house and all there was was
like one bed and one couch and one tv
but they did have a pool i swam laps it
was warm weather so 2021 was a whole
different story and then we got
vaccinated so we were excited about the
future
so it was nice the second time around
how crazy we got vaccine we were
expecting all this hoopla and two months
later people started getting
breakthrough cases and then they want to
start selling the [__] vaccine and
people like dog it's breakthrough cases
but you're not gonna die well guess what
nobody's [__] punching the ticket you
know i talked to a friend of mine
yesterday they just go
close the school district in jersey
down south my girl i grew up with is a
principal down there she's like i'm out
of a job for three weeks they're just
gonna lock it up for the [__] month
because by the time they get back and
testing and [__] yeah
so you know
i don't all these [__] breakthrough
cases it makes you think but then people
are you gonna die
what a [__] mind [__] for america you
know it really is sucks because every
time you get optimistic
there's there's new news and then the
news is always
uh it's always more alarmist than it
needs to be like the headlines are
always trying to scare you and then if
you read the article it's like oh it's
not that bad
they try to freak you out and at this
point i'm vaccinated i just got my
booster what am i gonna do i'm just i
you know it's not like they're paying us
to stay home i would love to stay home
and make money but it's not happening
for me so i gotta get out there and
stand up what's up how's the work
situation work situation is fine it's
not
the best but i'm surviving and i'm
working
and i just i like doing stand up so much
more than i did
before 2020. i'm just so into it i've
got new material obviously from going
down to new louisiana
and uh i just um it's exciting to do it
i i'm way into it right now you know
that's good man
no it's very good because it can become
a job and it can get tedious and it can
be especially traveling you know about
that traveling's exhausting and then the
crowds every night exhausting
but
it's actually good i'm not working
every weekend because it's just too much
you know you know that you sold me on
that philosophy a while ago you know two
weeks a month was your policy right that
was it or less yeah that's what i could
have listen yeah you have a schedule and
they look at these tours people are
doing
and there's you know you look at them
and you go nope
nope
nope and then you see some guys that
they get it they
you see that they're rounding it out
they're just trying to get out there to
stay relevant they're not trying to and
that's what i would do now if i was out
there i'd just be hitting
my favorite spots to stay relevant
friday saturday four shows get me in and
out no more drama no radio no nothing
we'll [__]
promote it if they come they come if
they don't what do you want me to
[__] do you know
i can't control this [__] what people
think or whatever it's not
wide open but then you look at like nick
games
and you watch you know you see what
tom's doing our good friend tom's
working a lot which is good for me
because i open for him sometimes that's
perfect that's good that is fine with me
you know you see what these guys are
working but they all have an out plan
yeah if you speak to tom he'll say to
you bro i'm doing this with this period
and then i'm done yeah
focus on podcasting i'm doing it you
know i spoke to bert he's like i'm doing
this for a certain time one more tour
yeah for me i had just been burnt out it
had become a job
yeah
and i wanted to unwind a little bit i'm
just coming to a new place i don't want
to land here and three weeks later i
gotta pack up on a tuesday i don't know
newark airport you know i gotta learn
you know i gotta attack it slow yeah
we were at new york airport together one
time i don't know if you remember and
you walked straight up you walked
straight up to jersey mike's sub shop
and you're like what the [__] are you
doing here you got real sandwiches here
we don't need no [__] jersey mics
and the kid was just like i don't know
what to tell you i'm pissed at jersey
mike
[Music]
that's okay if you're in iowa yeah i had
jersey mike's bro i can't lie to you and
it was good like three times and then my
[__] and then my [__] conscience
came into play
i'm a catholic and i think about our
[__] and then my conscience came into
play and i thought about how i'm
cheating on italian people who come over
here on a [__] boat with a salami to
give us culture and food and we're
[__] eating that [__] from [__]
fat mics whatever his [__] name is
jersey mike but meanwhile there's an
italian guy that he's got [__]
you know when the what do you call that
[__] when the pasta goes to your toes
and your feet hurt gout you know he's
got gout he's standing on his feet all
day waiting to make a [__] sandwich
and you're going to [__] jersey mice
[__] sucking it didn't come to [__]
fruition until i came to jersey and i
saw jersey mice the first time i saw
jersey mice in jersey i actually stopped
the car look in there and i had to think
twice if i had a gun in the car because
i swear to god i become isis i will isis
every [__] jersey mike's and then the
biggest isis i want to do is 42nd street
new
shoot the [__] olive garden down me
and 20 other [__] italians and we'll
give a [__] pass to curtis silva the
guy who from the guardian angels that
want to be mayor come on this is how you
be mad lock that [__] olive garden
you lock that olive garden up you'll get
10 million votes
[__] i'm sorry i get emotional
about olive garden and [__] jersey
mike's but enough is enough suckers dude
i heard jersey mike is from delaware
[__] jersey mike
[__] josie mike i'm totally making that
up i don't know if that's and i'll tell
you what listen let's talk
honestly yeah i went to somebody's house
maybe a month ago they were watching
football and they had a roast beef
sandwich with coleslaw
and they cut it you know they got like a
foot long and they broke it into 30
pieces and i ate one you know you're
there you got a little thc in your
system from the night before
and i took a bite of it and right away
it was like eating lamb
like it was like eating veal like i felt
guilty like somebody's [__] lamb is
dead
and i couldn't imagine why am i feeling
guilty about roast beef with coleslaw
it's not a cake i'm not gonna die it's
just three little [__] points like ah
it's the jersey mike's that's got me
[__] up
keeping you down dude now blimpy
let's talk about blimpy bass please i
think we never get to this blimpy is
deep in my dna
okay
now we're getting somewhere all right
yesterday about a week ago maybe two
weeks ago me jim florentine my daughter
and jimmy's son and my wife went to this
really good italian restaurant we were
running late
the guy called he goes i'm making pasta
come over we went down i love joe from
el nido i went i brought joe rogan there
i'm going to bring [__] mike there
one day when he's here past five because
i don't want him to drive up two hours
for el nido then he's gonna drive two
hours back forward
they'll call me i fell asleep in toms
river like you did last tuesday
my i took my daughter and my daughter
when we're going out we're leaving we're
talking by the door yeah i was like take
a card you know if you know anybody so
my daughter takes a card this is two
weeks ago yesterday she drops on me she
says dad
guess who i gave that cut then i go oh
she was my teacher
hold on here this is the restaurant for
you and she's like what do you recommend
it my daughter's like [__] yeah i
recommend it and she goes uh okay i'll
let you know how it is so i told the
owner what my daughter then he goes tell
her
he sent me back a text he goes tell her
to get the name and reservation
no mercy told him if you go in there
tell the owner you know me right my
[__] eight-year-old daughter
she's already jersey baby she's already
jersey dog you gotta she loves all the
you who's yeah like she likes bottle you
i gave her a candy at this like dad this
don't taste right like okay
they use different they use different
water there they use that philadelphia
water for the kids
[Laughter]
so i remember when i was in the [__]
second grade let's just say second grade
to herbie
uh i used i used to live on 88th street
yeah right in new york city on broadway
a little off towards amsterdam and on
86th street there was a blimpy base oh
my god oh yeah oh my god because i just
ate american food when i was a kid
because i wanted to be american right so
blimpy what's more american than [__]
blimpy you know libby's awesome yeah i
would go to blimpy every day and i
finally found the sandwich i liked there
was two blimpy sandwiches i like a tuna
with vinegar oil and a slice some
american cheese come on doug i'm getting
hungry now and the roast beef with
american with vinegar oil with this
tomato onion tremendous one day i'm
going to school like in the second grain
i'm like
[__] school
i'm going to move for a blimpie's
[__] sandwich
like my mom didn't wake up that morning
or maybe breakfast she gave me like
orange juice with emulsive of cotton and
i was furious i'm walking towards the
amsterdam i'm like [__] this
i'm gonna hide at the bodega to the bell
rings and then i'm gonna go to blimpy
base and that's exactly what i did but
when i'm in blimpy base as i'm walking
to the blimpy base who bumps into me the
chewing officer
oh [__] they go son how come you're not
in school i'm hungry
he's like what do you mean you're hungry
i'm [__] hungry that's why i'm not in
school
he goes so what are you going to do i
was headed over to the blimpy base if
you want to come over i'll buy you a
sandwich that's how [__] smart i was
in the eighth grade right
i was [__] second grade yeah you know
my mom gave me like a 20. that's like
eight blimpy sandwiches
i bought them a blimpy sandwich we sat
in the heat i'll never forget this and
there was a side door that took you
towards riverside drive and i remember
wiping my hand and going it was nice
meeting you he goes you're going back to
school lying on that i'm going to the
park
i went down to riverside drive just went
to the park i got home my mom's like you
didn't go to school
i got beat up but at least i had a roast
beef sandwich in my belly that's how i
knew the tuna from subway wasn't real
because i've been waiting for [__] uh
blimpy since jesus left
what is that what is the tuna in subway
i never read the article i just saw the
headline
mexicans they tried to cross the [__]
the rio grande river
where they drowned they pull them out
this their skin is soggy and they just
chop it up and
send it no [__] you gotta assume you
gotta assume
yeah like it doesn't take a genius i i i
listen i i have a relationship with
stakehome not recently because they're
[__] terrible but
30 years ago i had a good relationship
with stake them but if you look at the
stake of them now you're a little bit
more intelligent you're a little bit
more wiser
if you look at the stick and you're like
that looks like a black dude's die
you that's that's what goes through your
head yes black dudes died they did a guy
i got the motorcycle one of the guys
from not the mayans what was the black
motorcycle gang and sons of anarchy i
know it's a guy accident and they they
[__] their leg up and right away in my
mind i feel like the ambulance actually
calls like stakehome
um
white castle
or people who are the meter like kind of
white castle's horse
how do you say a prayer
yeah it's just all onions i ate that in
a hotel room one time and my hotel room
just smelled like onions for six days
and do you want to really detest a white
castle yeah white castle when you're
drunk
wake up the next morning and smell your
fingers you think you [__] fingered a
dead person it smells [__] horrible
and it makes you fart like crazy too
doesn't it am i wrong about that i only
have one i i like white castle when i go
my daughter we haven't been in about two
months but when we got here i took her
and she was like dad this is great we
would go up there on saturdays and come
over and watch the honeymooners
yeah we would split the 10-pack
yeah no cheese for her three with cheese
steamed yeah some [__] fries and uh
damn diet soda and then we split the
milkshake three ways dude this podcast
is making me hungry oh yeah you're gonna
be hungry when you [__] get out
that's what we do i just had a handful
of peanuts before it is
i need to [__] eat i had some
leftover chicken and cuban rice man and
it was good for lunch i went to the gym
i dropped my car off in service today i
bought that car january i've never
gotten the service
started making noises and [__]
i took it down to the subaru dealer this
morning so what's your future brother
what what are you looking at at 2022 i
mean i'm getting
i'm getting married in 2022 i've got a
uh i'm working on a tv show
uh
with um i don't want to give too many
details but it looks like it could
happen which is always exciting we know
those things these things don't always
happen but at least
it's something to be excited about and i
love the project my friend and i that i
went to film school with 25 years ago
were
we're getting it together and um got a
couple people on board already so i'm
really excited about that hopefully
that'll take off
next year and then just doing the road
and uh you know the full charge power
hour i do that podcast still i stopped
for a little bit and started that back
up again
and that ought to keep me busy i think i
also want to do a i also want to do a
half hour or an hour special soon
just shooting hopefully i can i can
concentrate on that and shoot that shoot
yourself i love what shane gillis did
yeah i love what shane gillis did the
new way to do it everybody he didn't
give up he pushed ahead
and he's making great [__] strides
you know
all these guys
i love it now that you control your own
destiny it's really cemented now that as
a comedian you don't need [__]
hollywood you need
uh a booking agent to book you but
anybody who could breathe into a glass
can book you sure anyone that's not you
can [__] book you don't believe the
[__] hype because all of them are
horrible right now like if i was to fire
the guy i'm with where would i go
because they all suck they're all
[__] thieves right sacks of [__] so
where would you [__] go they're a
little lazy too
very lazy
all we do is comics is go oh that won't
work well i'm going to try it anyway
what are you listening to a [__]
agent for
that's like listening to me about music
or guitars i don't know nothing
i don't know nothing i could tell you a
plan but i don't know comedy is what i
know like i would be a good comedy
manager now because i've done it for 30
years i know the obstacles and i could
talk to somebody and they would
understand but these guys
they failed at whatever they [__]
tried and now they're trying to pimp
human beings out and the fact that they
don't even do it right anymore they
don't even do it right they don't really
give a [__] look at my agent i told him
i didn't want to go on the road no more
no auditions
really
all the money i gave you on time you
hear about all these comics that all the
agencies money i [__] pay them that's
the first person i pay when i land
absolutely i write the commission check
and it's in the mail and they get it on
tuesday so all this good work i did now
you don't want to book me and [__] tv
and film you sacks of [__]
you know you miserable sacks of
motherless [__] pieces of [__]
you know and i get it i'm an old [__]
man but i still got listen rita moreno's
90 and she's still working
and that's my new [__] goal that's
what i'm going for i was already killing
myself you do know that but i was
already putting myself in the old guys
home and i snapped out of this [__]
coma i took a look at my ball sack i
sniffed it and i go what the [__] am i
thinking i'm no old [__] man i got
white my balls hair are white but i got
more blood in my [__] heart than most
[__] young kids i'm going
yeah they're not going to film your
balls and you're always castable they
always need your type no matter what
your type is no so i called the agent
this morning listen i'm committing to
this with you i really want to do it
i'll put
i'll do some better [__] auditions
you know that i'm looking for a big 20
22. like a fun [__] yeah man like we've
been living in hell for two [__]
years we need it two years two [__]
it feels like two [__] years you know
it is because time is just slowly
[__] ticking you know you know
we've all got you
what's that they got a bunch of
surprises for us in 2022 yeah dude yeah
we all just gotta hang in there and wait
for these three weeks to go by boy once
that january comes they're going to come
at us with some [__] crazy [__] so
i want everybody to be prepared for
2022. it's going to be a crucial [__]
time for all of us
i like what you're saying man i [__]
read your your uh your tweets every day
man
i i appreciate the inspiration and i
think you're right i think you're right
2022 we could spank the i'd rather go
out with a bang
and turn 60 in 2023 and then
get a job at costco
why welcome to costco how are you today
and people didn't i just see you on the
tv show yeah that was then this is now
[__] i'm now at costco's i'm just
giving out [__] stickers you're here
you know what i'm saying i got my face
and my name tag that's it i'm all right
but i'm not gonna [__] play lay down
sally and i'll tell you what
i'm getting happy again i'm getting
excited
i will i
think one of these nights
somebody's gonna call me and go hey man
take a ride me to a comedy club and i'm
gonna jump
and get on stage and i'm gonna go attack
it like i took two years off and fall in
love with it the way you did it again
for the art
let me tell you to fall in love with it
for the art oh yeah
well i know i was just gonna say like i
was nervous about i wasn't on stage for
a whole year
and i was nervous about how good i would
be but i just prepared for it
and everything was fine in fact it was
probably better than the last time i did
stand up because i was excited about it
i had the nerves going a little bit
i loved it it was so great and i even
had new i was even doing new material
the first
uh the first time back on stage and even
[__] with the audience a little bit
pushing them a little bit you know i was
in nashville though it was easy to do
it's easy my wife's calling in nashville
and i was thinking of going with him
maybe jumping on the monday night open
mic
at zayn he's going there and see theo
and whatever but i think that weak theo
will be in new orleans with his family
and
josh wolfe will be [__] running with
the jews you know it's the jewish time
of the year
that's what i did i went there because i
wasn't like interested in getting paid a
lot i just wanted to get back on stage
and new orleans didn't have much even
though they have a comedy club now but
josh does like a variety show there now
which is totally fun you can just go up
and do 10 minutes
and it's it's a lot you know how much
fun josh is yeah he's a [__] ride
he's starting
a lot of fun he yeah
i'm happy he got out of la i think a lot
of guys just needed to get the [__] out
of l.a l.a is not doing nothing for you
no more
get the [__] out of there it's such a
i'm happy to be the [__] out of that i'm
grateful every day that
whoever put this idea in my mind to get
the [__] out of there it worked and
whoever got me back here worked i'm
happy to be back here yeah
and uh
it's just i i
i wanted to take care of myself the
right way yeah i wanted to [__] get
healthy i wasn't i'm not healthy i
wasn't healthy for the last year this
[__] with me a little bit yeah yeah
but guess what yesterday i motherfucked
three people
that means i'm back and today i
motherfucked somebody early
which means i'm back that's how i know
i'm back when i get in a bad mood and i
have to tell people to suck my dick this
morning i went off on a guy
yeah i felt he came up to me the wrong
way and i apologized i called him when i
got home but hey you know
people started taking me for granted a
little bit like they were forgetting
that i'm a [__] sex knock it off man
be a good guy i mean i'll be a good guy
to you and right we'll leave it at that
you know
well i never knew the difference man you
you you never went away in my mind no no
no i just laying low and yeah when it's
time
you know when it's time i'm gonna it's
like they're gonna put me in a cell and
i'm gonna bust out of that cell
i don't know if it's going to be
tomorrow i don't know if it's going to
be in 2022 i think it'll be in 2022. and
i'll go straight
end 2022 with a nice show at red bank
we'll go down the [__] vogel theater
i'm thinking of doing a one-man show you
know yeah interested in maybe doing a
one-man show i have a lot of things i
like to do nothing concrete
but i'm trying to figure out 2022 2021
is done we got a [__] christmas
jingle
you drink a glass of [__] uh i eat a
grape and it's new years and that's it
that's that's it it's december one
today you know yeah that is one thing la
taught us is that the year's over
around december 10th yeah you know but
you might as well just call it now
because hollywood is slow right now
anyways show business is slow right now
it's been so so for it to go into this
was my time of the year
always december 1 to the 18th
yeah
i try to book a episodic to come out of
the box like there's nothing like
eating eating christmas dinner and
thinking [__]
yeah january 4th i go right to work you
got no worries that's one worry that's
so out of your mind you're like
that's so great i know i'm i'm just
doing some stand up but i got that going
for me i'm working in vegas on january
2nd really tonight
uh greg hahn's headline and i'm doing
the uh the middle spot
and uh
just eight days of destruction dude in
the warm weather
he's doing fine i saw him in uh
in april he's doing fine dude where does
he live he lives uh
north of l.a
uh i think ventura i think he lives in
venezuela yeah
i haven't seen him
since 1998.
yeah that's a long time we almost got
into a fist fight in santa cruz awesome
because he called me a liar he said
creative entertainment didn't pay
headlines 250.
uh-huh so i went in my car and i got
them to pay stub i was just saying dog
call them you like when you encourage
comics you like call them
he was in north carolina the room sucked
but it was 250 a [__] night when
you're yeah the headline and you drive i
did them with vinnie light bulbs we did
like three weeks we went to tennessee
[__] you go to west virginia you're
doing coal miner rooms
one place charged me fifty dollars every
time i said [__]
every time you said [__] they charge you
fifty dollars the guy goes listen i quit
at two hundred i go what are your
chances of getting that two hundred you
know i'm saying get the [__] out of here
you're like the blues brothers you owe
them money yeah
so i was trying to help him i'm like
greg call them and greg's like you're
bullshitting me and i'm like look at it
they pay headline is 250 and features
175. this is 99.98
but then he's like you're a liar you got
that printed up i go huh
craig what the [__] he was at three
yards then
yeah we got into a little pushing match
and uh a lesbian girl broke us up those
lgbtq is
they don't like [__] fistfights
around them mimi gonzalez that was her
name cuban jewish chick from [__] new
york city
dude
your life i was gonna tell you i was
gonna tell you that in 2022 you should
make a movie about it's joey diaz is a
superhero and you're all busting out of
jail you're doing all this crazy stuff
but the more i talk to you that your
life should be filmed every [__]
second i know you would hate that but
you're a [__] show man
you're ridiculous i'm ready to go like
i'm ready to go bert called me last
night and said if i wanted to be part of
the 5th of his 500th episode
yeah you know what i don't want to fly
but it'd kind of be nice to go to l.a
yeah
[__] uh put a pipe bomb and some guy
i gotta kill
i gotta i learned how to make a pipe
bomb now i could kill him
there's a couple people i want to go
visit out there i miss a couple of my
friends but i think i need to go out
there and straighten out some people
that flash mob i just got a hold of them
i sent them to the guy's house that's
[__] me
i'm going to send them over to 80 people
going to that [__] place and beat up
that [__] guy i told him they got a
lot of money in there a lot of
appliances
so you're going to la to do birds
podcasts and kick the [__] out of some
people
yeah is that what you're saying
awesome man go to la and point the flash
mobbers in the right direction
okay okay i got you i got you dancing
i got like three locations i'm in for
the small nickel
just give me five percent of whatever
you take and
the guy that you're gonna rob i want you
to give him a beat break both his
kneecaps i'm ripping here i want to see
an ear in my [__] house
i want you to nail me in here in a box
no i just this is why you got the part
yeah sopranos movie yeah i just need to
go out there maybe so if if i want i'll
see what the date is i really want to go
see joe and austin and do a podcast down
there because we always did that
december 27th
uh-huh
so i'm going to give him a ring today
and see if he's going away on vacation i
mean if i had 100 million dollars i'd
leave on the 25th and go to santa's
house
yeah santa suck my dick you know what
i'm saying this 10 million santa sniffed
that nut sack and that's no beard
[__]
i'm going to make a call for you because
i want you to do spots at the east side
comedy my buddy's running it brian oh
yeah dear friend of mine from zany's i
know him since he was in college
he's worked himself up the comedy ranks
he started at the laugh factory then he
got a general manager of zanies and
chicago and he just took the general
manager job over at east side comedy
club i know
you know brian morton i don't know him
but i've seen all this online and i
would love the hookup yeah he's a great
guy so i'll give him a call later on and
hook you up and i appreciate it
hopefully i could see you early in
january or you're always welcome to
swing by and get a [__] spare rib
with uncle joey i would love it it would
make my [__] life we got one of my
you're one of my favorite people in the
world was always great to work with you
on the road that's one thing i miss is
when you said that about new york and
the [__] sandwich i was like that's
right we used to have a blast on the
road
you're on a crusade squashing sandwich
shops i [__] love this [__] man i
miss you miss you too i'm happy you took
the time today i love you thank you for
your zoom working i've been working with
these comedians lately at the zoom suck
what the [__] you gotta work on your
zooms [__] you gotta fix them this
was an enjoyable [__] zoom you know
what i'm saying hell yeah dude i mean
you lucked out sometimes my zoom sucks
but we lucked out we love that
any dates coming up
uh yeah i'm doing uh vegas january 2nd
through 9th
and i'm doing a funny stop in coyohoga
falls ohio february
i think 10th through 12th that's a funny
one that's a good club up there in ohio
oh that's a good people
everybody
somebody will [__] even give you a
package full of meth or an oxycodone
crazy club that's a great club the club
owner is crazy he yells at the comics
from the back of the room he [__] he
calls his [__] he calls all the local
comics gay he's a [__] he's a maniac
i used to know one of them
down there yeah i used to know one of
the managers there he had worked at uh
craig's room in kansas city
big time [__] party
yeah he went up there he's the one that
told me don't give that girl coke
because she starts sucking dick no i'm
not gonna give her coke that's the first
person i'm gonna give cocaine to
she's sucking dick you know what i'm
saying if she don't suffer my dick
that's fine
she sucks somebody's dicks and makes her
day she's making the world a better
place she's making the world a better
place so give her the coke and hopefully
she'll lick your [__] nuts you know
what i'm saying
yeah what's going on with gosh you're
doing any road work with him or he just
said [__] it i did some work with tash
in august i did some la clubs and it was
a [__] riot
and i love hanging with that guy and
we'll see hopefully
you know
once a year twice a year i get to work
with him and that's always a pleasure
man that's always a [__] place that
guy did it right bro
he never got in trouble nobody ever said
he did he just got his job and said [__]
you [__] i'll just stand up
when i want i'll torture comedy central
have them pay me everything they have
yeah i heard one time they didn't have
money that week that women were giving
them jewels and [__] from comedy central
he works them heavy over there he's a
slave driver [__] yeah no yeah you don't
[__] around no he don't you don't [__]
around
yeah i love you matt full truck i love
you again have a happy holiday if i
don't see you man
you're always walking down here right
just all you gotta do is call let's work
it out man you come in the daytime we'll
take mikey to get some kung pao chicken
and [__] his wiggle flip
i'm all about it hopefully he comes down
oh really oh
he comes down he brings his dog he
leaves him in the yard and we shoot down
and get kung pao chicken
i give him some reefer and he shoots
home he's happy as [__] he sits in my
backyard on the [__] hammock
yeah with as long as your feet and [__]
it's [__]
that sounds awesome dude one last thing
what the [__] is that thing with a
dating game
oh young [__] matt fultron trying to
pick up [__] on the dating game or
whatever it was like that was like the
first month i was in la right so i went
to uh
central casting to sign up for extra
work
and then uh
on on the way out
the um you know the whoever books the
dating game you know asked me to come in
an audition and it was a crazy audition
so all the contestants were there and
you had to go up in
and uh and audition in front of
everybody and so it was like a stand-up
show but it was before i started doing
stand-up but i was just in the zone man
i was killing i was crushing and they
asked me to be on it and i said yeah you
know i wanted to do something i knew it
was like goofy but that was i was all
about goofy back then
you know and it was fun and i'm glad i
had the footage now because it's a riot
to see if they pick up hillary
introducing me no [__] nothing
it's funny because when i first got to
l.a i was telling mike i went to central
casting
they were
doing the extras for the titanic oh wow
and i remember driving to that little
[__] resort it was like a three hour
drive from l.a i left my house at three
in the morning yeah and i got there like
that like you gotta be there like at 5
30.
when i got there they had a line of
people that were gonna be extras waiting
to get their costumes yeah
when i say a line of people i say about
75.
yeah they were just there standing there
right and the guy said it'll take about
three hours to go through the process
and then you're gonna go in there around
nine in the morning
and we they were working until midnight
yeah man it was like a long [__] day
and i'm like
yeah i gotta go to my car i go do you
have an id and stuff like i gotta go to
my car and get it pm that's because it
was 35 flat
yeah it was 35 for the day or something
yeah that's tough man but the cell was
you're going to get in the movie if you
go down there right don't make your star
in the movie are you going to be one of
the people were you going to be one of
the people like falling off the ship as
it turned sideways one of those a waiter
you know whatever right right
i didn't give a [__] i didn't know
anything so [__] other than cook at the
end yeah when they said come down and if
we like you we'll put you in the movie
yeah you know i was down there i was
looking for leonardo
you know i went down it was lenient i
got it you're a big gilbert great fan i
heard yeah i love i love leonardo
dicaprio uh but i remember it was so
difficult back then because
you had to call an answering machine and
they're like we're looking for this type
and this type and this time i never
called on a day
that that like anything was available to
my age rage or age range or whatever and
i i just gave up on it after a while
because
but i was i was all about doing extra
work back then you know i wanted to you
know and it's worth it to do it at least
once just once just to learn the movies
yeah you know what man i wanted to do it
but then i got my pride
yeah i don't want to be no [__] extra
i worked so hard as a comic it was just
dent in my head
but uh
the guy used to come to the comedy store
at night and he'd sign you up there
and then he'd give you the jobs from
there with central casting he was on me
for about three weeks to guy yeah but he
goes i can't get you in until i get the
35 i'll sign up for you
dog send me down man let's see what's
going on if i get you're telling me i'm
going to be a star right yeah okay let
me go down there get in when i come back
i'll give you the 35 the guy wouldn't go
for it so i finally [__] worked them
one day and i go how about i give you
like 27.50
yeah hire me i'll give you the other 750
guys like in
so that's funny dude i didn't want to
[__] do it man
yeah but i love you
i'm saying ari said he used to go to
extra work and like leave yeah that's
what i did i left
a lot jimmy florentine told me he used
to do it in the city leave yeah he
figured out a way how he could leave and
they still pay him yeah if you're gonna
do that that's good i
now in hindsight
i don't know how accurate this statement
is but
yeah you think you want to be an extra
for a day just to see how the set works
yeah i think that that experience would
[__] you
when you see how shitty they treat
people yeah they treat people shitty
so i think that you would go there
they do they do i don't like them
like when i do work and there's a lot of
extras i'll give food to the extras i'll
steal from crafty
yeah give him a house and calm up them
and go you guys want m ms or something
yeah yeah you know they're sitting there
they eat last
right no i know they're they last they
[__] go you know it's it's not good
so they're below the pas
on a film set
yeah they keep them in their own pen
yeah the action
can't talk to anybody they're not
allowed to talk they're drinking water
and they got like two things on crash
services
listen man that hollywood game is rough
that's the introduction to it it's
[__] rough and i'm happy
i don't have to deal with those [__]
jerk offs no more and i don't have to
buy into their statements
but i love you matt i love you too man
you showed up and you got what you
wanted out of them
i made it happen on my own yeah they
were they're just [__]
you know witnesses that's all they are
i'm [__] witness you come off that
was great no it wasn't
stop blowing smoke in my ass i ate a
[__] bag of dicks and you're telling
me that was great right go [__] yourself
you watched that new kevin hart show
no i haven't seen it true story on
netflix
check it out it's an education for a
comic all right i'll check it out dude
i'll give you a call next week you're
good yeah i love it i love it i love you
all my heart i appreciate you doing this
i love you too man happy holidays send
you my love to your girlfriend your
fiance
i'm coming to the wedding i don't go to
weddings but i'll come to your wedding
all right good especially if it's in new
orleans
go down and eat some good jambalaya get
some [__] katrina shrimp get a shrimp
cool boy i love those shrimp boys
i love those [__] people try to
make pool boys around here they don't
know what that
that sauce yeah it's mixed with like
alcoholic beverages and [__] cat puke
and [__] not even blimpies can handle it
no you know what i mean you got to go to
new orleans i could go for a blimpy
sandwich right now i love you
i love you guys you need
for joining the joint today we love you
brother
love you too man i'll talk to you later
thank you peace
what's happening you bad [__] i
hope you enjoyed my little tata tay
with my man matt fultron i saw him at i
hadn't seen him in a long time and then
i saw him at the soprano premiere and it
was
it was great we just talked on the
street for a little while i hugged him i
kissed him matt's one of the real ones
in [__] comedy if he comes to your
town buy a ticket go laugh a little bit
giggle he's the real
[__] deal that was another fun-filled
episode of the joint we're making a
little comeback to end the year [__]
strong i'm not gonna let you down and
then we're coming back here in 2022 even
[__] stronger we got turns and
surprises and [__] like that so get
ready laughing gas is in stock
and that's all you need to worry about i
love you [__] have a great
[__] weekend and i'll see you guys
monday morning
december 6th tip
top [__] magoo stay black
[__]
all right cocksmokers i love you
[__] with all my heart i want
to thank matt fultrom it was just good
to see him and to [__] talk to him
like i said i bumped into the soprano
premiere and he [__] brought a tear
to my he's a great [__] kid support
him and all his stuff
and i want to thank you guys for always
having my back but most importantly real
quick listen
cbd
is one of the best thing that's happened
in the last couple of years it's really
taken the market by storm and it works
i happen to have the secret to who's got
the best cbd and i'll go with cbd line
i've tried like six or seven brands and
no but i even paid 400 for a bottle and
split it with lee one time and cbd line
is way better than all that [__]
that fast they [__] deliver to you
and they have what you need whether it's
the tape the back balls the gummies
the cream the ice cream like they have a
i don't mean an ice cream ice cream they
got like an ice that's cream and like
you know makes you it's like a menthol
type thing it's [__] tremendous i
love the tincture i love everything
about cbd line they've been with me for
like three years now people contact me
all the time to
help them out with their cbd
i'm with the lion [__] sucker so do me a
favor go to cbdline.com
take a look at all that great products
and read learn
pick a product that will help you in
fact they'll point you in the right
direction go to cbd lion press enjoy
your joint and get 20 percent off
delivered right to your house the best
cbd on the market and also coming at you
the joint is also brought to you by
draftkings listen everything's happening
right now this is the time of the year
when you want to be gambling at least a
little bit you don't want to be a
[__] god bone but i gotta tell you
some bowl seasons coming this week you
got alabama against [__] georgia you
got the ufc you got pro football listen
thurs tomorrow night that nfl game to
dallas i'm gonna give you a [__]
prediction right here dallas
has nobody they got six people they got
covert including the [__] coach
they're getting four they're giving four
i don't know what the [__] they give and
listen either players step up or i don't
see the dallas cowboys winning this week
even though i love the [__] cowboys
don't yell at me but what i got for you
here i got tons of action i got ufc i
got nhl i got pro football college
basketball
pro basketball and it's all
on draftkings not only that they got a
[__] uh uh digital hub that gives you
picks and helps you make the right
decisions plus they got a social network
that you communicate with other [__]
degenerate gamblers like yourself
and uh have a good time on there now if
sportsbook isn't your thing yet it's not
available in your state that's fine
draftkings got you we got [__]
draftkings dallasy fantasy sports
tremendous draftkings is giving all new
customers a free shot and a million
dollars in total prices with that first
deposit who else does that nobody
[__] draft kings is safe to cure
and reliable and best of all you can
withdraw your cash whenever the [__] you
want that's the most important thing do
me a favor if you like playing blackjack
poker slots they got a live casino and
don't tell nobody but usually at nights
they have happy hours like [__] three
hands or 25 bucks wins your thousand
it's [__] crazy but it's all up to
you download the draftking sportsbook
app download the draftkings fantasy app
it's time to throw down and make some
money if you go with sportsbook one
dollar gets you 103 bets if you go with
fantasy one dollar gets you millions of
dollars in prizes
okay now when you bet that dollar they
score with promo code joey
then you're in the [__] money all
right so always remember to put promo
code joey in there you got to be 21 or
older new jersey indiana pennsylvania
colorado new customers only minimum
five dollar deposit that's it that's all
i'm asking you for is a nickel and a
dollar wager you get one per customer on
these and i'll make you illinois quick
restrictions do apply see draftkings.com
slash sportsbook for [__]
details now if you got a gaming palm i'm
not here to put you in a pinch call
1-800 gamble but if not head over to
[__] draftkings and let's win some
[__] getus i want to thank
draftkings i want to thank cbd lion
don't forget to visit on it the black
monday friday sale continues 60 off i
want to thank better help for their
great therapy i wouldn't be here for
them if it wasn't for them and i want to
thank zip recruiter for having our back
but most importantly you [__]
savages for being [__] savages i love
you stay black have a great weekend
don't forget the ufc bet mickey
and have a great weekend with your
family tip top [__] magoo
don't worry i'll get a new candle next
week i love you [__] stay black
you